il ya tout au long des marchés de
provence qui sentent le matin la mère et
le mini départ point feu nous melon
ceseda avec par ci par là quelques gains
ce qui dans ce voyageur de la nuit
moi qui en ribambelle est franchie des
pays que je ne voyais pas ga au point du
jour
de trouver sur mes pas ce mobile est
payé
et
le matin qu'au bas
c
voici pour 100 francs butin de la gagne
un peu de safran et ax deux filles que
voulez-vous pas vrai un bon cas je ne
pêche ou bien d'abricots voici
l'estragon et l'avait l'échalote le
jaune poisson de la mari charmant te
brûler vous pas vrai un bouquet de
lavande ou bien quelques oeillets et par
dessus tout ce qu'on vous donne on est
très lac saint omer et qui n'ont fait ni
mais s'il ya tout au long des marchés de
provence tant de filles jolies
tant de filles jolies qu'au milieu des
fenouils melon sellers
j'ai bien de temps en temps
quelques idées qui danse
voyageurs de la nuit moi qui en
ribambelle et croiser des regards que je
ne voyais pas
ga au point du jour de trouver sur mes
pas ces filles nues
le matin
à
et
100 francs du tadla ganic un peu de sa
pan et 1 kg de figues voulez-vous pas
vrai un bon cash de pêche ou bien david
ico voici l'estragon et l'avait
l'échalote de jolis poissons de la marie
charlotte voulez-vous pas vrai un
bouquet de lavande ou bien quelques
secondes et par deux si tous
on vous donne en étrennes l'accès qui
lisent
promet
et qui mangeait